well I was asked to give a speech that
was five minutes long in this spot and
I'm beginning to have real empathy for
my students that I asked to give a
five-minute presentation of their entire
year's work at the end of the year and
so I'm much more empathetic to that
problem that they have now after having
this assignment so it's 1973 I'm here on
campus
I live at 46 13 Fillmore Street
overlooking the church overlooking
Central Catholic and my long-term dear
friend who's in the audience sorry
I've seen it a long time anyway
she and I decide that we're going to
outfit my truck my van and we're going
to travel across the country camping
along the way between Pittsburgh and
Seattle where my new job is at Boeing
and so we're gonna camp the whole way
and I'm out in front of the house
building this thing you know making
cabinets and putting up folding bed in
it and all and some guy walks by don't
know who was and said you know there is
a table saw in the design studio to
which my response was something like
what's the design studio or even more
like what's a design I was an electrical
engineer at the time anyway so I found I
found the shop and to make a long story
short from that moment I feel like the
luckiest guy in the world I know that I
was put on earth to do exactly what I'm
doing
and it just feels so good one of the
things I hope for you is that you do
that with intention figure out what your
fit is in life you get to be my age you
know sitting around with the old guys
metaphorically smoking cigars and
drinking cognac I don't think we do that
anymore
but and so many of my friends say
something to the effect that you know I
had a job that looked good to society
but it felt bad to me their whole lives
it's so um it's so disappointing and so
I hope for you that you will
use the your design skills and your
intention to find your fit in life so as
Terry was alluding to I think at least
from an old guys perspective design has
moved from the kids table to the adult
table very recently and I'm so excited
about that I can't tell you you know
recently whenever a CEO or the president
University came to see me they would say
something like where can I get glasses
like those you know or I need a new
briefcase will you help me you know and
that's what it was like that was my sole
responsibility to the hiring but today a
CEO comes to us and says can you help us
improve the educational system of Peru
or the president of versity comes and
says can you help all Stanford students
have confidence in their creative
ability this is a different thing from
you know where to get those shoes and so
I couldn't be more I couldn't be more
excited about it it's quite the time for
design and you guys are just joining it
at the right moment I really think
design is magical I just am so excited
when I go to see the kind of end-of-year
presentations in the studio of the
student work or you go into a corporate
design studio and see what what they've
done they've made something out of
nothing it's amazing they see beautiful
clever just elegant solutions to
problems and it's just amazing to see
that happen and so um as much as I enjoy
that talent I also enjoy the way
designers think the mindset that they
take right and so these designers I
think just really have amazing
superpowers that no but no other
discipline really has things like
painting a picture of the future with
their ideas in it
I'd love to see that you you you paint
this picture of what you think is going
to happen or what you think should
happen and then by making it visual
other people can help I mean lots of
other people lots of other disciplines
get involved once you have that picture
of the future and that's what that's one
of the superpowers of designers I also
think being routinely innovative is not
normal you know I mean everybody else is
trying to figure out how to solve some
problem and designers are not that way
in my opinion they they they're much
more comfortable with ambiguity than the
normal discipline is and so you're in
this position designers are comfortable
in this position of not knowing which
allows you to stay in that position long
enough to come up with something that
really is meaningful to do as opposed to
I think most people that I'm involved
with feel the need to define the problem
quickly so they can get on with it
but once you define the problem so
quickly it's hard to pivot to a really
interesting problem or to a real
innovation and so that's one of their
superpowers and the other thing is this
holistic human centered approach you
know that this kind of you know you can
come at things from a digital from a
technical approach or from a business
approach but we tend to come into it
from the human side and I think this
really lowers barriers for other people
to come in and collaborate along with us
to start new to start new collaborations
you know it's just a much better
approach to the kind of holistic design
that we do now and I think designers
also have that superpower so today I'm
very excited for designers and design
designs having to respond to new
conditions and new requirements but
we're at the center of biggest as
carries over at the center of big issues
you know healthcare government education
climate change and we're also trying to
account to accommodate new disciplines
like designing for data these are all
big movements that are really making
this an exciting field so we finally
have a seat at the table and I think the
question is you know we've never had
this seat before what are we going to do
with it so my challenge to all of you is
how are you how are we how are you
going to use this new position to to
make a better world
Thanks
[Applause]